Welcome to the lecture on database implementation.
So in the last lecture, we have started looking at B-trees.
And you are hopefully all familiar with how a B-tree roughly looks like.
As we know, the introduction to databases.
So here's a picture of a B-plus-tree.
So a multi-way tree where all leaves have the same distance to the root and every node is at least half full.
And we have seen how a lookup works.
So we start with the root, then go down and then we find the entry.
Because our nodes are pretty wide, so they can have hundreds or even thousands of entries,
we use binary search based in the leaves to speed this up.
And we have seen there are multiple ways to make even better binary search, like branch
tree, binary search, or try to interpolate all these kind of tricks.
So this is roughly how a P3 looks like.
This is a logic for lookups.
Now what about inserts?
So how do we insert?
The good thing about P3s is insert logic is so simple, you can implement it by heart.
have to look up in a book.
So while the red black tree you most likely cannot implement by heart, a Btree you can.
So Btree is pretty easy.
So you firstly perform a lookup because we must find the appropriate leave node.
So just like for searching, we'll go down to the leave page where the entry should have
been.
Now then the next step, so step two, we check is there enough free space for the new entry.
If yes, easy.
So we just add the new entry.
is that we keep the leaf node sorted, which means that if these are my entries here and
now my new entry would belong here in the middle, then of course I must move everything here to the
right, then move myself into the middle. But this is the only challenge, otherwise it's easy.
Now of course a tricky problem happens, what happens if the node is full? So we don't have
enough space in the node. What we do then is we split the page into two and then we insert the
Now, what does this mean precisely?
So this is my page here,
there's many, many entries.
Remember that they are sorted.
So I cut them into,
I think this is roughly half.
So now after the split,
I have two pages that are not full.
So first page up to here,
let's call this element here,
m for example.
So the last element is m.
m then this is m plus one then the new node gets everything here also half
will everything from m plus one and so on okay so m for the media this is the
middle element and and now of course because my f now two half will pages I
have enough space for my new element so I insert it wherever it belongs now I
I cannot know before and if it is the first page or the second page after the split, because
if a value that is smaller than m of course it ends up in the first page, if it's larger
than m it ends up in the second page.
Yes, so we insert it wherever it is.
So but now we have two pages, but our parent node, remember that above us there sits a
parent node.
So the parent had many children, I just point them away, and of course one of the pointers
here pointed to us.
But now we must, and this had, let's call this else, the last element here was the separator
page. So now we have split our page into two. So what happens now, what must happen now is,
you insert the new value here into our parent and this now has the value L and the old entry
no longer has L but instead has M as separate. So the largest value on our current page.
So this is how it works after split. So when my leaf page is pulled, we split it into two,
So the new insert is my new element is appropriate set and the maximum of the last page is a
new separate of the parent page.
So the M basically, logically we insert the M with my old page and then the old separate
is updated to point to the new page.
Okay, now so this is easy, but what happens if my parent page is full too?
Because it could happen, then we do the same recursively.
So if the inner page is full, we do exactly the same.
So if this is my page, everything full, I split it into two pages, now half full, should
be half, you know, and then here another page half full.
So these are the two halves that we had.
And then we insert the separator in the appropriate page and we insert a new separator between
these two in my parent page.
And if I have no parent page because I am the root, then I create a new root and lets
So this is the insert, pretty simple.
You can remember if the page is not fully, we insert, if it is fully split it into two
and insert a separate then my parent.
And this we do recursively until everything is done.
So inserting is easy.
Now what is unfortunately not easy is deletion.
So insertion is easy, deletion is not easy at all, because there are so many things that
can happen.
Remember the criteria that we had for B3 was, so that guarantees logarithmic lookup was,
every leaf node has the same distance to the root and every page except the root is at
least half full.
With our insertion logic this happens automatically because if it's full we break it into two
which means we get two half full pages and then we can insert.
Now with this deletion we can violate this half fullness criterion.
So how do we do this?
So first we start performing your loop as usual.
So we find the leaf entries, we move down the tree, so this is my tree here, I move
down the tree following pointers until I come to the leaf node, for example this one.
And of course I have more entries here.
And then, so this is the leaf page that contains my entry.
Now is my leaf page at least half full?
No, sorry, first we remove the entry.
So we search the entry, we remove the entry.
Now I check afterwards, is my leaf page at least half full?
If yes, I am done, because my balancing criteria was not violated.
So that is good.
Now what happens if my leaf page is not half full, so it is less than half full.
So now I have a problem, because I must make it at least half full to guarantee logarithmic cost.
So what happens now is, I look at my neighboring nodes.
So in this case, my neighbor is this one here.
So I look at my neighboring node and then I check if I can take away elements from my
neighboring node.
Now basically there are two cases, either my neighboring node is more than half full,
then I can just take elements from my neighboring node to make myself half full.
Or if my neighboring neighbor is also just half full, not over half full, then I cannot
take elements away because otherwise the other node would be under full.
But if this happens, then I just merge my neighboring.
So if that happens, so my neighbor is only half full, I merge with my neighbor,
this must work because I'm less than half full, the other one is half full.
So I can merge them into one big node and one full node.
And then of course I remove the separator for my parent and then recursive is the same.
So it could be that my parent is less than half full and so on.
And we do this until everybody is at least half full.
So this is the idea.
Now one pretty important trick to realize here is that, first, how do I find my neighbor?
Because in the general case, this is a very difficult problem.
So there was a paper long time ago from someone from MIT, I think, who studied all the problems,
all the cases that could occur in B-tree deletions.
And these were tons of them.
So incredibly many things can happen.
Because semantically we have another neighbor here.
So this is, and because this here is also a neighbor from us, at least from a logical
perspective.
Because this leaf node here, so this one here, holds the next largest value after myself.
So in theory I could balance with that node.
So this node here could balance with that node.
But trust me, don't do this.
So it would work from a logical perspective,
but finding this other element can be surprisingly difficult,
because it can be very far away from you in the tree.
So don't do this.
What you can do instead is,
you know that you must have at least one entry that has,
you have at least one node, other node,
that has the same parent as you.
So this must be the case because otherwise,
if you have only one entry,
then we would have eliminated my parent node.
So because my parent node is also at least half full,
I must have at least one neighboring node.
So what we do is we go to my parent
and then I check my neighbor.
I don't know if it's a neighbor
is to the left or to the right,
but one of these two must exist.
So there must exist a node,
it's the same parent.
And you take that node,
and then you can balance with that node.
only go one step up and one step down and not further in the tree.
And then you can find your body to merge with and then everything works fine.
Now, nevertheless, deletion is pretty complicated.
Insertion is easy to implement.
Deletion, at least if you want to do this properly, is very difficult in many cases,
even more so because you have realized that there are many systems that many users that operate in
the same tree so there's multi-user aspect which we didn't cover yet but trust me multi-user access
with deletions is particularly difficult now and because of this problem so many systems just say
i don't implement it yeah so they accept under full pages they don't implement the proper deletion
logic.
The only thing that they do is if a page is really empty, so that there is no element
left, then they remove the whole page.
So the trivial empty nodes are removed, otherwise under full pages are accepted.
And this is of course much easier to implement.
And the argument in favor of this approach is they say, you know, but in the long run,
then the system has more insertions than deletions.
Because if this would not be the case, then your database would be empty.
And because if you have more deletions than insertions, your database is empty after some
point and empty databases are uninteresting.
Therefore, we assume that we have more insertions than deletions.
Therefore, it's okay to just ignore the problem.
So because the empty pages will be filled again.
And at the first glance, this is a plausible argument.
At the second glance, unfortunately, you can construct sequences of insertions and deletions
where this argument does not save you.
Because this argument is only valid if your insertions and deletions are uniform over
the whole domain.
But if for example, you insert consecutive increasing numbers, and then you will
time to time delete all numbers that are not a multiple of 10 for example.
So then you get a lot of free space because most of your values are deleted.
And this free space is never used because your new values are larger than the largest
value you have ever inserted. So you can construct degenerate examples where the
simple deletion strategy is not good enough. Because of this, you should implement the full
deletion, even though it's complicated.
So I know it's pretty hard to implement, but no's less you should implement the
full deletion logic just to cover all the corner cases correctly.
Okay, so now we have seen insertion, deletion and lookup.
Now there are some other operations that we need.
The obvious one is a range scan.
So because remember we wanted to use an index both for point lookup and for range queries.
support range scans and range scan is pretty simple basically what we do is
we search do a regular look up so a point query for the start conditions we go
down so this is my tree I go down my tree until I find the leaf node where my
start condition is could be of course that my start doesn't exist so then it
takes the next largest value so for example here so this is my start let's
And then I continue reading everything on this page
because everything on this page here to the right
is larger than the start.
And when I hit the end of the page,
then I follow the next point.
I remember that B plus trees have typically a next point.
So they can't go next entry.
And you know, everything is also larger than the start
and so on.
So we do this until at some point we hit a value
that is larger than my stop condition.
And then I stop of course, because I know everything further to the right is also larger
than my stop.
And this is pretty efficient because we'd go one traverse and then we go from leaf node
to leaf node.
And this is particularly efficient if the leaf node that we point here, I give them
our numbers, that is L1, L2, L3.
So if L1, L2, L3 are next to each other on disk, yes, if you're consecutive disk, then
And this here is brutally efficient.
Because if you go to one position,
then we just read linear from disk,
and this is as fast as we can be.
Of course, if I catch the memory,
then it's always pretty fast.
But even on this case,
this range scans are very fast once you have started.
By the way, if you have such a B-tree,
so a B-tree where the nodes are physically next to us
on disk, then we call this a cluster to cluster. And clustering is very good for performance.
Of course, if you have updates in between, your clustering might degenerate over time.
Yeah, because you write them nicely at one point on disk, everything is good.
Then somebody inserts something in the middle. So then of course you can no longer have everything
consecutive on disk. But conceptually, so this works pretty well.
Now, what do we do if we have more than one attribute?
So far we just said we have one value and our examples always just use simple integers.
But in SQL you can generate indexes not on one attribute, on many.
So the easiest way to achieve this is of course to say create table and then you blah blah
blah, so the attributes and then we say primary key.
primary key, a comma b.
So this is easiest way to construct a multi-attribute index.
So now we must check if the combination of a and b is unique.
So we index both attributes.
And so how do we do this?
So for the index, it doesn't really matter.
The index treats a, b as one compound value.
So of course it's a bit larger than a single number, but for the index, it doesn't really
we store them both as values.
And then we compare them lexicographically.
Now what does this mean?
So if I have two pairs here and I want to compare them, then we say the first pair A1,
A2 is less than the second pair B1, B2, if and only if A is less than B, okay, the obvious
thing, or A is equal to, sorry, A1 is less than B1, or A1 is equal to B1 and A2 is less
So this is called lexicographic ordering, this is just like a telephone book.
So if you think of a telephone, usually they are sorted primarily by last name, but if
people have the same last name, they are sorted by first name.
So this is just the same here, so we sort them on the first attribute, and if the first
attribute is the same, we sort them on the second.
Otherwise, so compound keys behave more or less like atomic keys, so keys with just a
So if you do a point query, so if you just search for one value, exact value, then the
difference between a compound key and atomic key is pretty trivial.
But interesting thing is if you have a compound key and you bind only a prefix, which means
in our case here we might search for all values where a1 is 5.
So this is, so we bind only one part, my total key is a1, a2, this is my total key, but now
I want to say something about a1, say a1 is 5.
And this is then internally transformed into a range query because this says, okay, this
means that a1, a2 is between 5 and minus infinity, this means basically the smallest possible
value of the domain, it depends on which data type A2 has.
So, but this is the smallest possible value, well let's call this here, I don't want to
call it inmin, let's say with min value, and this here is maximum value.
So, we say, so this gives me implicitly a range query, and then we of course execute
this as a range query.
Okay, so this works nice.
This is now a trick question, what happens if the user says a2 equals to 5?
So if that happens, then we have tough luck, then we cannot use an index.
So you have to remember, if you have an index and a compound attribute, you can search for
a prefix of the attributes, but not for a suffix or any other combination.
So just to keep the telephone book example, if you have a telephone book and you know
the last name of somebody it's easy to find. If you just only know the last names, also pretty
easy to find, of course you get more candidates because they get everybody with the same last name
but this also works. But if you have only the first name then you have no chance because then
you would have to look at every entry in the telephone book which of course you don't want to
do. Now so in the index you can search only on a prefix. So if my index attributes for example are
A, B, C, D, then I can't search for A, B, C, D, of course I can only search for A, B,
C works, I can search for A, B works, I can search for A, this also works, but if I search
for anything else, like only for C or for B, C, also this doesn't work, I cannot search
for this.
Okay, another tricky problem is, this doesn't occur with primary case, but this occurs with
explicit indexes.
So if somebody says create index,
so you say create index.
Now the interesting question is,
what do you do if my index values are not unique?
So if I do create index, I can say I want to index,
for example, all students by, let's say,
so create index, I can use a project with index,
let's call this create index student name.
has absolutely no meaning, you only use it to remove the index later.
And so your name, you give it as other as it doesn't matter.
So on students name.
So now we create an index on all the students,
I want to index the students by name.
And of course I can do this.
But so what do I do if I have multiple students with the same name,
which is actually quite likely.
name is not particularly unique so there are multiple people with that name so therefore
i will have duplicates or can have duplicates
in i mean with name you will want to have too many duplicates but let's assume some
not so smart user decides to create an index not on the name but on something that is
totally non-selective for example on
on, let's say, country where they are born.
Of course, we have many different values.
We have people from all over the world, but nevertheless, many of our students come from
Germany.
Now, which means that if you index students by country, then countries that were born
in, then a large fraction of your tuple will have the same value.
Potentially thousands or even millions of values will have the same value.
This of course is bad.
Because so this means that we can no longer easily identify a single tuple just because
of value.
Now, as long as you only insert and look up, you might not notice it that much.
But what if somebody does a delete or an update?
So somebody says, I want to delete a certain tuple.
I want to see delete, delete.
So somebody says, delete, delete from students.
Oh, should try it next.
Delete from students.
student ID equals 1, 2, 3.
So if you do this, first you ask your index on student ID,
please find me student 1, 2, 3, then you find it.
So you use the first index, you use index on student ID.
So this gives you the tuple ID.
Now I can physically delete the tuple, but of course I must also remove it from all other
indexes where the tuple is part of.
And so how do we do this?
So now we can of course retrieve the country, so we can retrieve the country, so fetch country.
And now, yeah, but what now?
So if you just have the country, if you try to locate the tuple within the relations,
this doesn't help us because there can be thousands or millions of, of course not millions,
but in general there can be millions of entries with the same value.
And therefore searching for this value with the regular scans is not a good idea.
And so instead what we do to fix this problem is,
we make sure we never have a non-unique value.
So all values that we store in the index have to be unique.
So this parameter key, this happens naturally,
of course, because we know that it's unique.
But what if you don't,
and index a non-unique value,
so then we use a trick.
Because remember, so what we said,
you can search for every prefix of a value.
So basically what we do then,
if we index the key as provided by the user,
It can be multiple attributes of course, but we index the key and we append the tablid.
So the tablid works as a tiebreaker, so it means if the key is identical, the tablid
nevertheless will be different and therefore we can distinguish these cases.
So we can distinguish entries with the same value by tablid.
And with this, we can now locate an arbitrary element again in logarithmic time.
So if you'd want to delete a certain element, we first find the element, take the tablid
and then we take the key and tablid, we know this is unique, we can't do this in logarithmic
time.
The downside of course is that we have a higher space consumption because we must store the
tablid, but this is the price you have to pay.
So, the table ID must be stored.
But this, in reality, this space consumption is not that high, because in the leaf nodes,
we would store the table ID anyway.
Remember that in the B tree, we store key, table ID values, so we have the table ID.
So the only space cost that we have is in the inner nodes, we must now store table IDs
too, which usually we would not do.
So, space consumption increases a bit, but really this increase is minor.
leaf nodes and inner nodes, space consumption is minor,
and therefore we can just afford to do this.
And doing this is essential to get logarithmic access cost.
Now, if you implement all this,
you get a B-tree that allows you insert deletion and lookup.
But what do we do if you have more than one user
accesses a page?
Yeah, so we must somehow protect our sense against concurrent threats, which run other
queries simultaneously.
Now, in the buffer manager that I have used so far, we always locked a single page,
but this is clearly not enough.
So just locking one page, I mean, walking one page is necessary, of course, but not sufficient.
Now, so to illustrate this, so if you have a leaf node and I find the, I move somewhere
here, then I lock the leaf node.
This is okay because at this moment in time I have the leaf and then I can read it as
long as I want.
And if somebody else wants to update the leaf while I hold the lock, then the other one
has to wait until I'm done and then I'm finished.
Okay, for leaf nodes it's good enough, but for inner nodes it's not good enough because
what can happen is, so I have an, I have a, I go here, I have an inner node, I lock or ledge,
the ledge is a database slang for this. If it's latching, we mean short-term lockings like a mutex,
mutex is a classic ledge. So we ledge the inner node and then after we have ledged the node,
we find out, okay, what is the child node that I want to go to? For example, I want to see,
to go to this, then I would, at least in a naive implementation, I would release the lock on the
inner node and then I would go down here, I would go to that node and then I would try to find the
value. This is not safe because in the meantime between my unlock here and the lock here, there
is some time spent between this. A small period of time perhaps, but it is time. And if I am really
unlucky, somebody else overtakes me in the meantime and also locks the leave node, which means I now
And then for example, it splits the leaf node into two, and then my values I'm searching
for ends up being at that new leaf node.
But when I finally managed to lock the page, I only find the old entries, so I miss my
value because I'd go to the wrong page.
So locking a single page is not good enough.
So the traditional solution to this problem is called lock coupling.
So which means whenever you access a page, you access both the page and its parent page.
So which means when we start, so if this is my tree, so I start and I lock the root, of
course I have to lock the root.
And then I find out, for example, I have to go to the left.
Then I also lock the left node and I still hold the lock on the root
That's which means that nobody else can in the meantime can mess up the meaning of my page. So I hold both locks
Okay, then I have the child I have the child page then I can release my parent page
Now I find out what is my new child that it matches it in for example is the right child here
Then I go here acquire the lock so for a more short moment in time
hold both locks, then I can release my parent and so on. So this is called lock coupling.
Also there's a children's toy that you might know potentially. So this is, I believe the
brand name for this is called a splinky or something like this. So this is basically a
metal coil that can walk down the stairs. This is a fun toy to play with. By the way, there are also
other vendors that don't want to make advertisement for them. So it looks like this. So you have
of your coil here and then the coil goes down here and then it pulls it ends up and then
moves it away from the parent stair so to say and then falls down on the next page.
Then again pulls itself up, takes away from here and then moves it down one step further.
And this is exactly like lock coupling works.
So we, for a short moment in time we hold two locks but then we always flip down to the next
So then we no longer have to hold all the locks.
We just hold two locks for a short period of time and then we continue.
The nice thing about lock coupling is that not only prevents problems with concurrent access,
but it also has no deadlocks.
So classic locking obviously has a certain risk that if multiple people lock the same page,
in the wrong order, then we get a deadlock.
Here, this cannot happen.
And because you always lock from root down to the leaf, so there's an order in my locking
and therefore no deadlock is possible.
That's why this is very nice.
And so lock coupling solves our correctness problems.
Now already we want you, it solves our correctness problems, but it does not necessarily solve
our performance problem.
But we come back to that in a moment.
Okay, so first, so with lookups, everything is easy because I just go down from the roots
down to the leaf.
But what about inserts?
Now the problem is, if I insert my split, if my page is full, it propagates up.
So you know, I start here by going down, everything is good, so I lock everything in one order.
But now if my page is not full, everything is also okay, you can just insert.
Now, but if my page is full, then I want to split this into two, and then I insert a new
separator in my parent.
So suddenly, and of course this can happen again if I'm unlucky, so this means that now
suddenly I go from leaf down to the root, sorry, yeah, leaf up to the root.
And so this is a problem because even, so if you do traditional log coupling, we have,
we might have locked, have locked our parent because at least for one short period in time,
So remember when we went down here, let's clear the back arrows.
So when we went down, we locked the route, we locked the first level, we released the
route, now we lock the leaf.
And you know, you see in this short period of time, we hold both the inner node and the
leaf node.
Now what you can do in this moment is we check if you have enough space.
If yes, we can release the inner node because we know that we don't have to split.
So in this then we can release the inner node.
If we don't have enough space then we hold the lock on the inner node so we don't release
it.
And then if my inner node has to be split, I can update my, sorry, if my leaf node has
to be split then I can update my inner node because I still hold the lock to it.
So that's okay, we can do this.
But what happens if my inner node is full too?
So then I would have to go one step further.
So this of course we cannot do, because if you start doing log coupling in the wrong
direction then we get that looks.
Now there are multiple ways to do this.
One way to solve this problem is so called safe inner pages, which means basically when
we go down we check if my inner page is full.
and if yes we split it even though in this moment we don't need all the space
so we see my inner page is full and then I split it and because I did the same
with my parent page of course this means I never have to propagate further
than one level and I already hold the level as one level so when we go down we go to the root
If my root page is full, then we split the root page, create a new root.
Otherwise I go to this page and check if the page is full.
If yes, in this moment in time I still hold the log to my parent, which means I can split
myself, update the parent and I am done.
Otherwise I release the log to my parent, I go down to the leaf and again the same.
So we check inner pages in the moment they are full, even though we don't need it, but
not strictly needed, but this guarantees I said a proper split never propagates higher
up than one level and this is safe with low coupling.
Now downside of course is we waste one element on the inner page because we could have waited
one insert longer.
So we do it one insert too early.
But that's okay because I mean if I can fit 1000 elements on the inner page, if I do this
Too early means this is not a critical issue.
So I'm wasting one promilio of my space, that's okay.
That's a very small overhead and the logic is pretty simple.
So I don't have all this nasty, complicated, going up logic.
No, this is good.
Now, the main problem with save pages, I mean why don't we always use save pages, the main
problem with save pages are strings.
Because if you have string values, it's not so easy to decide if your page is full.
So how do I know if I have enough space for one more element?
And so for integer values, that's not a problem because I know I can just need 4 bytes or
8 bytes, it depends on my data type.
I know when I can squeeze this in.
But if I have string columns, I don't know this.
And this makes save pages unsuited for variable size records.
So I cannot really decide if I should split this page or not.
So what we can do as an alternative is what is shown here, this is a so called restart
strategy.
So basically what we do is we first try using simple log coupling.
So we just go down and then it.
So if we do not have to split the inner nodes, everything is okay.
We can split the relief node, but we don't split the inner node.
So otherwise, if you do have to split the inner page, then we release all the ledges
and now start again, but during the second walk down, we keep all the ledges up to the
root.
That means that we don't release them, we keep them.
And now we know that all operations can be executed safely, because I have all the ledges
up to the root.
The good thing is this is pretty easy to implement, simple to implement.
Downside of course is if this happens, I mean keep all the latches up to the root,
this is expensive because I really lock my whole path.
So this is a pretty invasive operation.
On the other hand, this happens rarely.
So how do you know this?
I mean if you can fit about 1000 elements on a page, this means if you split a page,
In the inner page, roughly every 1000 inserts, that depends on how you implement it, perhaps
every 500, but roughly every 1000.
And we also split the inner page after we have 1000 inserts in the leaf page.
So it means every 1 million elements we have to do this.
This is really rare.
So this restart here happens extremely rarely and therefore we can afford to do this.
Yes, it should be really rare.
And then we can now we can handle
both fixed size and variable size records.
Fine.
So that's, this covers this case.
Now, there are some more strategies,
I mean, even with log coupling,
I mean, if you do this, then log coupling works.
The problem with log coupling is,
log coupling is more expensive
than you think at the first glance.
Because what does this mean?
This small picture here.
So if you look at this, we know every node here contains for example 1000 elements to
keep it simple.
That means that if I lock this node here, then I have locked 1000 elements.
If I have locked that node, then I have locked myself and implicitly because nobody can come
by me, I have implicitly locked at least concerning concurrent traversals, my descendants too,
which means that I have locked implicitly 1 million elements.
Because I have 1000 shared nodes, each with 1000 entries, which means by locking this
in a node, I lock at least for a short period of time, 1 million elements.
And so this is pretty expensive.
So, I mean, you have to, in worst case,
is this page that I want to access to this leaf page here,
that's called this L1.
In worst case, the L1 page is not in memory,
so I have to load it from disk,
which means I, let's call this I1.
So I access this I1, I have not locked this one yet,
well, I'll try to lock this.
So I have locked the inner page I1,
so I want to access leaf page L1,
and wait for this leaf page to come,
this time nobody else can access for example L2 because they cannot pass by me.
So I block L1, nobody can access L2 and so I'm blocking implicitly 1000 pages, meaning
one million elements just because I wait for my page L1 and have locked the inner page.
So this is not so, I mean it's correct, but it's not so super great from a performance
perspective.
So performance could be better.
And therefore people said, hey, wouldn't it be great if we don't do this?
So wouldn't it be great if you only link at most one node?
So one node we can lock, but we never lock more than one node.
So this means we lock I1, then I figure out, okay, I want to go to L1, so I know the node,
then I release my lock here and then acquire that lock here instead.
That means I still have to wait until A1 comes from this,
that's true, but in the meantime,
everybody else can go to A1 if they want to.
That's why I don't prevent this,
I get much better concurrency.
So this is the idea of B-linked trees.
So not the whole idea.
So this is the motivation of B-linked trees.
Yeah, so this is what they want.
The problem is, if you do this,
what happens if somebody splits a page behind myself
in the meantime?
Yeah, so I want to get to L1, but I cannot therefore,
because I'm scheduled away,
I don't get to lock whatever.
It could be that the moment I came L1,
my data element, so let's say,
I'm searching for this element X here,
until the point in time
that I finally managed to get to L1,
X has moved somewhere else.
Can happen because somebody split the page.
Yeah, so this means I jumped here
is gone.
And then the idea of be linked trees is to say, okay, I do this, I willingly accept that
my element might be gone.
But because I always have this next pointer here, so if I am searching for a value and
I see the value that I am searching for is larger than the largest value that is on my
current page, I just go to the next page.
So I proactively go to the next page, even though I would not go there, but naturally
I go to the next page and then if x was moved to there, I find it.
Of course, it could be that it was split again, so I have to go to the next page again.
So I follow the pointers here until I either find x or I find elements, values that are
larger than x and then I know for sure that x cannot exist.
So then I can stop.
So this is a so-called B-link idea.
So we go to the neighboring pages and to go there.
By the way you have to do this not only in the leaf pages but also on the inner nodes
because the inner nodes the same can happen.
So I go to an inner node until I arrive there, somebody else has split the page, therefore
I have to introduce the next pointers on inner nodes too.
So, if somebody goes here, doesn't find its value, can go to the next point and so on.
So this is already pretty complicated, but this can be implemented reasonably well as
long as we have only lookup and insert.
What is a total nightmare in this B-Link tree is deletion.
Because with deletion, suddenly values can not only move to the right, but at least in
principle can also move to the left.
So because if I merge them, then they can be balanced with the neighboring nodes, so
it means my values that I'm looking for goes to the left and not only to the right.
And therefore following the next pointer is not good enough.
Now as there are solutions for this, basically this boils down to, you can only merge the
a tree or delete a node if you are sure that at this point in time nobody is currently
going down to this. Yeah, this creates some special programming mechanisms like an epoch
mechanism or something like this. Pretty difficult to implement and, but as I said, many people just
don't bother with this deletion problem, so they don't implement this correctly, then of course
it's easy, but if you want to do proper deletions in B-link trees, this is possible, but quite
challenging.
Now just for completeness, I want to cover one technique more, that is strictly speaking
not on the slides, but nevertheless is pretty interesting.
The problem we have here with synchronization is, with log coupling, is basically a problem
that we have in all kinds of hierarchical data structures.
The problem is that the root here is a bottleneck.
Or in general, the higher up nodes will be visited much more frequently than the lower nodes.
So that means we have many, many logs here, so we make many dots here, many dots here,
a few bit less here, and then even less here.
So this will be extremely hard because everybody goes through the root.
This is of course bad for concurrency.
Interestingly, it's even bad if you have no concordial problem at all.
So just assume everybody's reading.
So reading is not a problem.
So everybody can get a read log on everything, because I mean, readers don't conflict with
themselves.
So you can have one million people reading the same notes, no problem, conceptually.
But in reality, this is a problem.
So if you acquire many read logs here,
so if you do log reading, log reading, log reading,
and so on, many of these,
this will be a problem in practice,
even though semantically it's not a problem,
but in practice it's a problem.
Why?
Because this log must be implemented somehow.
And the classical way to implement this
is to use a read writer log,
In first approximation, it's a bit more complicated,
but in first approximation,
read-writer logs look like this.
Read-writer log, it means you have two kinds of fields.
You have an exclusive bit here, exclusive bit,
and then you have a counter
that tells you how many readers we have.
Ready, you need probably at least one bit more.
But this is how a very simple read-writer log
could work like.
So you could say, okay, when you try to get,
you lock something in exclusive mode,
you check if this bit here is clear.
If yes, you check if everything is clear.
So if there's no reader and not an exclusive bit,
and if yes, you set the exclusive bit to one.
And of course you do this using atomics
or some other mechanisms that is thread safe.
And so you set this to one.
And of course, if you cannot set this,
then you have to wait until this changes.
And if you read this, the end you increase the read counter.
So this you increase the reader here.
You basically plus plus on the reader.
And then nobody will create an exclusive log as long as there are readers.
So this is classical implementation read writer log.
And this is of course, semantically correct.
But in practice, it has very poor performance for this because this log that we have here
at the root of this node is changed all the time.
changing and then many threads try to change the same memory location this is slow.
Now because on the practical level the cache lines that holds this read writer lock here
will bounce between the different cores because everybody will try to update this counter
all the time this is very slow.
This is a performance problem even without contention.
So, therefore, there is an alternative approach that allows you to solve both this contention
problem in the log and the concordial problem in concerning other readers as well as log
coupling.
And this is something that is called optimistic log coupling.
So, how does this work?
Optimistic lock-up link.
And basically the key idea is that we assume that if a system is fast, conflicts are unlikely.
Of course conflicts can happen, but most of the time we have no conflicts.
Therefore we optimize for the case that we have no conflict and we do it as follows.
So we don't, if we replace my read writer log with an optimistic log.
And we still have an exclusive bit, but we don't have a read counter.
instead what you have here is a version.
So now and how can we, how do we do this?
If you do exclusive access, if you do write logs, you do traditional logging.
So you would get a log here and a log here and so you do everything traditional.
But most of the time we don't write.
Even when you insert you have to realize most of the time we don't write because the inner nodes
So for example this one here then that one here and then we probably will only read
So let's say we read this we read this and then we write this most of the time
If the node is full is not true of course, but again we optimize for the read case and
by with the B3 insert
999 inserts will only write the leaf one will also write inner nodes
So let's first assume we only write the leaf node.
So we read the inner node, we read the inner node, we try to write the inner node.
If this is not possible, so if you realize, oh no, you have to split this, then we start
again.
We start again from the root and then we say, read the root node, but now on the second
level I acquire a write log.
Because I saw that I had to split the leaf node.
Now of course this is racy.
It could be that the second time with my restart, somebody else has already split the leaf.
So I no longer have to split the leaf.
But this is okay.
I mean, you have one write lock too much, but it's okay.
So now at this point in time, I can split the leaf node because I have a write lock
in a node.
Now it could be that I also have to split the inner node, but then again, I give up,
start again and now restart and now acquire write locks from here and have all the write
locks.
becomes more and more rare.
So that you have to do this extremely unlikely.
So therefore we now ignore the writer and only look at the reader.
So how do the readers operate?
So if you have a reader on the leaf node, then in first approximation we do nothing.
So we just read.
So I go to this node here and I read.
But then you ask yourself, okay, what about concurrent writes?
I mean somebody can write this while I am reading.
First we do two things.
First, this is what we call verify here basically.
So here this lock, let's give this a name, let's call this a zero, let's lock zero.
So first we, when we try to read the leaf node, then we say, we make a local copy.
So let's do it like this.
So let's call this here start.
Then we say certifyL0 is readL0.
So we read the log.
Now if somebody is in this moment in time modifying this page, then we have to...
C1.exclusive, this means we have to,
somebody else is modifying this page in this moment,
while I'm coming, then we go restart.
This is unlikely, this is the route after all.
Go to start, then we restart.
And then we try to find the binary search on the page,
whatever we have to do.
So binary search, binary search on the page.
Now we did the binary search, but remember that we don't hold visible lock, because nobody
else knows that we are reading.
So we are reading the page, but nobody knows this because we don't increase the page point
as a reference counter.
So this means somebody else can modify the page while we do the binary search.
And we don't know this.
So what we do at the end, before we go to the child node, is if not validate, validate
C0, go to start.
So we restart.
So now how's the validation work?
So validation says, validate C means first of all, the current log is equal to my certifier.
So remember I stored the log in the beginning.
So I check if the log is the same after I'm done
and
not
C dot exclusive. It's not a lot exclusive.
So basically I validate a log. It's if
it's currently not held in exclusive mode and it was the same as it was as it got it before.
So now perhaps I'm not sure if I explained this before. So when I
when I do a write, let's say I do a write here.
When I begin the write, I set the exclusive bit.
So I set here, so lw.exclusive is one.
Then I do my stuff here.
Then when I'm done, then I say the version is increased and then I release the exclusive
bit.
So this is how I update words.
which means that a reader can check if somebody has modified the page while he was reading
and by Jack is looking at the version.
So after his read, he checked if somebody changed the page in the meantime.
If not, then the read was safe.
So I didn't acquire a log, I just validated at the end if my read was okay.
And if yes, if not, I try again because it means very unlikely that somebody modifies
it while I'm reading.
So if it happens, I just restart.
I mean, you could even rate limit this,
like you try a few times and if it doesn't work,
we get a real log or something like this.
But in practice, you don't need this.
You can just restart.
So this means you have to read the root node
without doing anything.
Now let's go to this one here, L1.
Because I figured out that I need L1.
So then let's say here,
take the credential here for the certifier
for the next log.
then I read L1, so I get the next log.
Just like in log coupling, the only thing is I don't write, I just read.
So now at this point in time, after I read this, if I must validate, so if not validate,
I must validate both the parent and the child, or not validate, validate C1, then go to restart.
Go to start so and after this point I can forget
So this works just like lock coupling I look at the route I
All my reads are inherently unsafe because it's commodified
Therefore before I do anything based upon the value that I get from there. I must validate
Okay, so after I've validated I can't go to this note here
After I have accessed this node I accessed a one I must validate if my reference to this page was still okay
I can't forget this so I have an optimistic log here
I have an optimistic log here and after I got the second optimistic log
I can't forget the first optimistic log just like in log coupling
yeah so you log couple down optimistically
until at some point you come to a leaf now if you only read you can
probably stop here if you want to insert the end at some point you get a real
real log on the leaf and
technically speaking even if you do a real
a query, so a range query, on the leaf level probably you want to get a read writer log.
Yeah, because you hold this page for some time because you are running a query, it can take a
while and then you don't want to be optimistic because let's be honest, the longer a query runs,
the more likely is that your optimistic assumptions falls. Somebody else will modify the pages in
the meantime. Therefore, if you do something for a serious amount of time, then get a real log.
But this is okay, because if you do something for a serious amount of time,
the lock doesn't matter maybe we can get the lock and also this we will do this only on the leaf
levels and we don't have high contention on the leaf levels on the inner nodes where we do have
high contention because everybody goes for example to the root we don't want to acquire a lock unless
we have to now so we don't acquire a lock and so we only lock optimistically with inner nodes on the
leaf nodes we mean mean for point queries we could do this optimistic too for other queries we do a
real lock or even exclusive lock if you want to insert.
And if you do this approach, then you don't have this problem with,
neither of the problem with B-Link nor with this lock coupling,
with traditional lock coupling, because somebody else can bypass me,
where I don't hold a real lock on the inner node.
So somebody else can bypass me.
I only have to check afterwards if my inner node is still valid.
Now this is a pretty neat technique to get high concurrency on a B-3 data structure.
But this is a newer technique, therefore it is not on the slide.
So you will not find it in traditional books and database systems.
But if you search for optimistic log coupling, for example, you find a paper where Victor
Lise and some of my former PhD students, now he is a professor in Jena, and he described
how to do this.
performance if you do locking in tree structures like B trees.
Okay, so we have seen now insertion, deletion, lookup, range queries and concurrency for traditional
B trees.
What we have not seen yet are bulk operations.
So now what are bulk operations?
Assume you have your database and then you want to import a large amount of data.
database import yeah so far you have all your files you have all your data and
files a few million records now you want to load it into a database now what you
could do of course is you could just do 1 million inserts and also would be
semantically correct yeah so you do insert tupper by tupper but in practice
this is slow yeah so 1 million inserts is probably slow I mean if you think
about the poor b3 I mean if you're there if your data comes in a funny order you
we do random IO all over the place.
We touch the same data multiple times,
so this is all very slow.
And so therefore we don't want to do this.
And by the way, this is true for virtually all systems.
Inserting millions of tuples is slow.
And so therefore here,
millions of inserts, of inserts is slow.
So what you do instead is you use something that,
Unfortunately, this is not standardized.
Each database system does it differently.
Oracle, for example, doesn't have a copy statement.
I think perhaps it does, but I think it doesn't.
But they have a dedicated program instead, so a bulk loader.
By Postgres does it from SQL, bulk loader.
Or some other mechanism.
So each system does it differently.
Copy is Postgres.
And so what the copy statement does basically is, it tells the system, here is a file with
input data, please load the whole file.
And if this is a million entries, that's okay.
And the same with this bulk loading tool, it also gives them files as input and say,
please load all the records.
And this is typically vastly more efficient than thousands or millions of inserts, much,
much more efficient.
load large amounts of data quickly.
So, but now how does this work internally?
Yeah, so now how can we bring data into our Btree quickly?
So we know that it's coming
because the user does a copy or backlog statement.
So we know that it's coming, but how do we do this?
Okay, so the first thing we could do is
we could sort the data before we insert it.
And I see we sort the data by the index key.
and this already has a good good properties because now we know that we will so the data
we will always everything right everything here then we write everything here and so on
there because we are sorted so my get my data in in increasing order so therefore i fill my page
from by p trees from left to right okay so therefore this has locality better much better
I obey have good locality.
But even though this is the case, in practice this is not ideal.
It means better than a random order, much better than a random order, but it is not
ideal.
In fact, in a way it even triggers a worst case.
Not concerning performance, performance might be okay, it might not be that bad, but concerning
space utilization it will trigger the worst case.
Now why is this a case?
Just think about this, we have the first leaf page, then we write, blah blah blah blah
that's not what it's full.
So then we split the page.
Now I have two pages,
you have an inner node of course,
and I have two pages.
First here, this one is half full.
The second page is also half full.
Yeah, and because my data is sorted,
I insert of course in the second page to the right.
So I'm continue until the page is full.
Then this page is full, I split it again,
this you know it and add two half full pages and then i continue inserting here and then split it
again and so on and so if you insert data in increasing order in a b tree performance will
be okay but space utilization will be bad because all your pages will be half full
yeah because we always split the right most page therefore all your pages are half full
This is of course a bit unfortunate.
Now there are multiple ways to tackle this.
One way is to realize if you are the rightmost page and this is happening to you, you are
split, you can look at if is my left neighbor only half full, if yes, I put my left half
to my left neighbor just because I know that monotronic increasing inserts are frequent.
So some trick like this you can do.
So then you will get nicely full pages, but this requires extra coding effort and it's
not so totally simple to implement.
In fact, if we know that we are bulk loading, so if we don't have regular inserts, then
we can do better even easier.
So we don't have this magic recognition that I'm the rightmost one, you can do this always
right.
Okay, so and this is how we build an initial B plus 3.
So initially means my relation is empty.
So no, there's no data inside so far.
And then I bulk load a large amount of data inside.
So how do I do this?
So first I sort the data on the index key.
And as you do this, of course, to get locality.
And we know that in the Btree, we have the data in sort order.
And so we sort my data.
Then I've spooled my data into leaf pages
and I don't use the regular split logic.
I split it, instead I just make the leaf page full completely.
So I have the first leaf page and I fill it up to the rim.
So I make it completely full.
And then when this happens, my page is full, then I go to the next page.
The only thing I do is, if this happens, I remember the largest value I had here and
we write this, so the largest, let's call it the separators, and I write the largest
value here, L1.
this page.
Then I fill this page completely, L2, the largest value here, I write the largest value
in the next, in a separate file.
I fill the next leaf page completely, L3, and again, write the largest value, and so
on.
Now until the largest value of the last page, Ln.
Okay, so this, of course, is probably not full because this is the last page.
So now what happens is, in this step I will get all my data into leaf pages and all leaf
pages will be full, except for the last page.
So now this gives me the lowest level of my B tree.
Now I form the next higher level.
What I do is, I take the separators from the file and now I spool them into inner nodes.
So I do the same trick.
So I fill this until it's completely.
And then the largest value on the first node, let's call this i1.
And again I write i1 in a separate file.
And then I fill the next largest value here until I get i2.
I2 in a separate file.
And so on.
So which means I take these separators here and I spool them into an array of inner pages.
Until i k.
Okay, now I do this again.
Once I text these values and spool them into inner pages, until everything fits in the
inner page.
So basically I create one level, next level, next level, next level, and so on for my B
tree.
So each pass here, so this is of course the lowest level, then comes the intermediate
level.
So I take my separator, spool them into inner pages, and remember the largest value, and
until I have only one inner page.
This is then my new root.
Now, of course, it depends on how many values you have,
but it could be that you have only one inner page,
or could be there also only one level of inner pages,
which means one inner page,
or it could be that you have two levels or three levels,
it depends on how many values you have.
But we spool them in there
until everything fits into the root page.
And the beauty of this approach is that,
first we only do sequential I.O.
we only write data sequentially.
Also this separate the values in the temp files
are written sequentially.
Everything is done sequentially.
And we get a perfect compact cluster B plus three.
Perfect means all pages are full
except for the right most page.
And it's clustered because each page
that is next to each other logically
is next to each other on disk.
Now so which means if you do a range query,
you do a beautiful sequential read on disk.
So perfect performance.
So this is, and it's fast.
The whole thing here is fast
perfect B-tree. Now this is called backloading. So it works very, very well. Now this is easy if we do
the initial B-tree load, but what happens if you insert data into an existing B-tree?
That's more difficult. So we start the same, so we start the data and then what we do is we
merge the data into an existing tree, which means we read both the input, the new input and the
And we merge them.
So basically we use the same strategy, we form new pages, remember the separator and
so on, just as we did before.
The only tricky thing here is step four, namely, we start a new chunk once a page would contain
only entries from the original tree.
So what do you mean with this?
So to illustrate this, assume we have only two pages initially, both full.
Or perhaps some more pages, doesn't matter, could be some more pages.
So now a new entry comes, many multiple entries, but one is good enough, a new one entry that
we want to merge, or a few entries that we want to merge into this.
So now we would start, these are the new entries, I could draw them like this.
So if you would merge them, let's assume by the way this is not that large, a small amount
of data.
If you merge them, what would happen is I start writing here, I form a new page, new
leaf page and start with the content that I had.
Then comes my new content.
So I write in, merge it in there.
Then I continue with the content that I had.
And of course the original page doesn't fit because, so I went up to here, let's say I
can fit it here and then I form a new page and it takes the content from here.
So the remaining part and now what if you would implement it naively
What would happen is you would take this page and start filling it in here?
And yeah, but then of course what happened is you rewrite all your leaf pages
because clearly you would start
Filling because everything is shifted because here's the same problem. You cannot form
Can I fit everything on a page or everything it would squeeze you to a new page?
So if you have 1 million further pages coming here, you would rewrite all the 1 million entries.
Of course, you don't want to do this.
What you do instead is you try to stop this merge by accepting under full pages.
So if you realize that you have a page that contains only notes, values that already existed,
because this here is old, this is old, and this is old.
So everything's old, it's just shifted.
If this happens, you try to stop this by accepting under full page.
If you just take the tail, this might not be good enough because then you are less than
half full.
So let's take a bit from this page too.
So then it's at least half full.
Then we have the remaining part fits on a page and then we stop.
So we have one page more and then we stop.
So the remaining 1 million entries, we do not have to move because we managed to create
a new run that is identical to existing pages.
And we want to do this of course.
So once you notice that only old pages are relevant, we don't do this.
And then of course you do the same on the next higher level because we got new separators
from this, this has to be merged into existing separators and so on.
So then we merge this.
And of course this is not so easy to implement, you see already what we have to do here, this
step here is not so easy to implement.
The good thing is we minimize I.O. because we still do sequential access.
Disadvantages, we destroy clustering. We can no longer guarantee that neighboring
pages are next to each other on disk, clearly because not all pages were updated.
But nevertheless, this is usually a decent compromise.
Now I should mention that some systems support the initial backlog, but do not
support incremental backlog like this. So they can do initial, but if you do this
So if you load data into existing trees, they will just do individual inserts.
Also they will sort the data and do individual inserts, but will not do this fancy re-merging
here because it is not so easy to implement.
But sorting and inserting at least is already better.
Now if you look at the documentation of Postgres for example, what the Postgres says if you
want to do this here.
So if you want to bulk load data into an existing B-tree and you insert a non-trivial amount
10 tuples or 100 tuples, it doesn't matter,
just do inserts.
But if you want to insert thousands
or millions of entries,
what Postgres suggests is you first throw away
the existing index.
So your alternative basically is to say,
drop index, drop index, then you do copy,
copy, so you insert all your data
and then you do create index.
So this is what Postgres took,
because they don't support it.
alternative. So the alternative to do this, this incremental backloading is to say, forget the
index, copy everything into the database and recreate the index, because this is of course
the initial backload. This here, it corresponds to initial backload.
And because then we throw away the index, we create the index from scratch,
which means we read all the data that we have and we treat this like an initial loader.
Okay.
So this will be faster than this.
Now if you are really fancy, I mean fancy in the sense that you have a big commercial
enterprise system and you have a lot of users all over the world, then you might have a
problem with bulk loads because bulk loads are fast.
So there's good performance and so on, but they are disruptive.
Because while the bulk load is running, so I mean, think about this, what we're doing
here.
So we're building the B3 layer by layer.
So lowest layer, next layer and so on.
So while the bulk load is running, we cannot use the index.
So we take the B3 offline, build the index, update the index, and then we can take it
online and then we can run queries again.
Which means queries must be halted during the meet.
It means they are not strictly halted,
means they can run, but they cannot use the index.
Now, so they have to use table scans
so they can read everything.
And some people, at least some enterprise customers say
that this is unacceptable.
Taking the index offline for a significant amount of time,
minutes or so, this is unacceptable
because then queries will be terrible slow during this time.
So the alternative is an idea here
that is called a partition B-tree.
so basically what you do is you create an artificial column in front of your key
so usually we have we have something like key one key two and so these are my keys
and now the partition feature says in front of all this you put an artificial number for example zero
this is position zero okay now all your data have an additional partition key in front
And we didn't talk about storage of B-trees yet, but I mean if you have a B-tree that
supports prefix compression, then this zero is only implicit, it's not really stored.
So you know that's a zero, but it doesn't cost you space.
So it's more or less for free, this prefix here.
So this is your initial import.
Now if you do another import, so if you byteload more data, then you create a new partition
here the next bioglutier take one in front then you have here key three then another one key four
and what happens because of this is this artificial column key here of course is that
the new values will all be larger than existing values so it will be appended at the right so
basically if you draw a picture here my patient partition by partition zero might be the left
part this picture here partition three might be that part and partition four is that part
And because of this construction mechanism,
we know that new partitions are always constructed
on the right.
This means that we don't have this complicated merge logic
because appending something on the right is easy.
We can do this without taking the B-tree offline.
Appending on the right is easy.
Just appending in the middle is not so easy.
Okay, so we partition the B-tree
with an efficient column, and then we create data,
we create a new partition, we append it on the right.
The benefit is the partitions are largely independent, at least logically.
So we can append to the rightmost partitions with the highest partitions on the right hand
side.
So indexes are always online.
And now make no illusion here, so we want to get rid of those partitions because when
you see this in the moment when we come back to the drawbacks, the partitions also have
disadvantages when we are searching because we must look in all partitions.
to have that many partitions, I mean one, two is okay, one is best, two is okay, but much more than
two we don't want, don't like to have for three perhaps, we don't want to have more than this.
And so, but what we can do is we merge the partitions and we do merge them lazily.
So, which means that we don't take the index offline, we create the index as it is, and then
we take a few tuples here from, from in the background, we have background jobs, it takes
a bit of data from here and merges it into this partition.
Then we then partition 3 became a bit smaller.
Then we take that slice, merge it.
We take that slice, merge it.
And we can do this as a background job without taking the Btree offline.
If you always rewrite small parts of the Btree.
And if you wait long enough, then partition 3 is vanished and everything is moved into
partition 0.
Then we still have partition 4, but this will also vanish over time.
So over time we do this.
We can even do this only when beneficial,
which means we can do this, for example,
only when there are queries.
If nobody queries, then we can just add partitions,
and if nobody cares, we just leave it as this.
But the moment that somebody does run a query,
then we start merging,
or we trigger background jobs that doesn't merge.
Now, there are also some drawbacks, of course.
If you have multi-partitions,
there's no global order anymore,
which basically means we have to look in all partitions.
x, we don't know which partition x is.
Therefore we must query all partitions.
And this only makes sense if the number of partitions is not that high.
As this is what I said, at some point we must start merging partitions.
And another drawback is, so far everything looked easy.
What about deletion?
Because when we say bulk update, usually we mean inserts, so copy is an insert statement.
But we can also do have bulk deletions or bulk updates and this means we must remove data and
Of course we do again. We don't want to take the index offline. So it means we must
Store the updated or the deletion information somewhere in the new partition like if you do a bulk delete you might in partition 3 say
I want to delete all these records here and
They are still in partition 0 which means that in partition 3 is where we store something that is the literature really calls anti-mata
Because during a query we will merge, so if you search for x, you will search for x in
this partition and we search for x in that partition and we will merge these two results.
Because it could be that partition 3 contains an update for x or contains a deletion flag
for x and therefore it's the name antimatter because if you get an x from here and we get
an x deleted from here then they annihilate each other like antimatter so then in the
The result says no X.
So we must merge this update information across partitions.
And this is not trivial to implement.
Pretty tricky to implement and also cost you a bit of performance in the queries.
So this is the downside.
Great advantages that you can do back operation in this tree here without taking it offline.
This is a great benefit.
And I think they are, I'm not 100% sure of SQL Server really did implement this.
At least I've wrote papers on board this house how to do partitioned B-trees
I'm not sure if it's a commercial product perhaps it is but at least a big commercial vendors have looked at this
architecture to to offer
B-trees that don't have to be taken offline during a back operations
Okay, so far
so we have seen all kind of
fine things about B-trees
Now there's one dark secret that we didn't talk so much about
namely that B-trees are much more complicated than you think in the moment that you have
variable sized keys.
If you have fixed sized keys like only integers or so, then life is easy.
Because the definition says each B-tree node, except the root, contains between k and 2k
entries, which means every node is at least half full.
And this makes your life easy.
So we know when a node is full, we can merge nodes easy and so on.
Because we can just count and then decide
if emerging is possible.
But in reality, many elements are not fixed size,
but are variable size.
Means the obvious example are strings.
Mean strings can be long or short,
but there are also other reasons why
tuples might be variable size.
Like you have variable length encoding,
you might have nile compression or other kinds of things,
or combination of these, you know, you have compounds.
And then we no longer know in advance
how large a key will be.
for example, not easily decided if an inner page is full.
Just because we don't know how long
the next separator will be.
And another assumption that we make in my Btree
is usually that the key is opaque,
which means that the Btree does not understand
the content of the key.
Now there are special Btrees that work particularly well
if we know that we have exactly one string.
Because if we have one string,
we have some games we can play.
But in the general case,
So this is my key, so I have a blob of certain lengths and this is the key and I don't know
what the content is.
So this is my key.
And the B3 must store this.
Of course there is a comparison function, so we can compare two keys with each other,
depends on the semantic of this.
But otherwise you have a byte range of variable size and you must store it and you must do
this properly.
So this is the problem that we have.
Of course what you can do is you can ignore this problem and just say, so what?
pages for my leaf nodes and my inner nodes because slotted pages can store just this kind of data
just fine, so no issue here. But if this will be correct, this will run into problems.
And this is what we see here. So this is now of course a constructed example to illustrate this.
Assume that we want to store the following entries. So we have keys, a short A string,
then a long B string and short C string, a long D string and so on.
So alternating long and short strings.
And so each entry here has either the length one or the length eight.
This is by construction.
And now assume that my key, my nodes here can hold only, for example, 10 or so.
So a bit higher, which means we can, oh no, sorry, to make it correctly, it must hold 9.
we can hold nine.
My node here can hold nine,
which means if I construct my P3
with the bulk loading algorithm that I saw,
I put A and B on a node, then the node is full.
Then I put C and D on a node, then the node is full.
Then I put E and F on a node, then the node is full,
and so on.
And I do this for all the nodes,
and this is the leaf node that I get.
Okay, so this is the leaf layer.
Then I always take the largest value
that I had on each page here, in this case B,
and then we form the inner nodes.
quit a B in a node, then I take the highest level, the highest value here is a D and this
would be, I mean if we really build this page by page, then this would be a separate in
the next high level.
And so then I have the Ds and then I have the Fs and so on.
So it takes always the largest value on each leaf node as separator and moves this higher
up.
And this means of course that because unfortunately the long keys are my separators, I can only
fit one key on the inner node, which means I have a very deep tree.
So this tree here has depths one, two, three, four, depths four, which is pretty deep for
a B tree.
And it has very poor fan out in the inner nodes because this inner node only has two
child pointers.
hypothetically I would have constructed the leaf node slightly differently, namely like this.
I would put an A on the first leaf node, okay, it's not very full, but I do this regardless.
And then I put the B and C on the second node, and then D and E on the third node,
F and G on the next node, and so on. So if I do this very small change here, then suddenly
my B tree has only depth two, instead of depth four. Of course, this ignores a bit that we need
space for pointers, but this to just to illustrate this huge difference.
By using a different separator value, we could shrink the Btree depth dramatically from 4
to 2.
This is much, much better.
And this happens because lengths have different size.
So we want to have separators that are short because then I can fit more on a page.
Okay, so this is basically the observation.
Now how do we get there?
So first of all, what we see here, separator choice is crucial because this affects the
fanat and space consumption.
And if we just use the standard B-tree algorithm that we had and use it with verbal length
keys and just do it best effort, so the moment that the base is fully, we just split it,
then we can, all the traditional guarantees are off.
In particular, we lose the logarithmic depth guarantee.
that we are logarithmic, at least not with a reasonable base, if we implement the B tree naively.
And solving this is a non-trivial problem.
For the bike loading case, there do exist algorithms that solves this, and even greedy
algorithms. So the idea is that if you do bike loading and you want to form a separator,
So you want to stop a page at some point.
Then you pick the smallest value separator such that the residing group size varies within
a constant factor, which means we don't make the page totally full, but we say we make
it between 90 and 100% full, for example.
So we give some leeway and then we pick the shortest separator such that we achieve this.
We can do this in a greedy manner.
Now, there's a pretty interesting plots paper that talks about this problem.
It shows that you can even do this in the dynamic case.
So not only backloading, but in the dynamic inserts.
But this is totally non-trivial and in worst case even forces us to rebuild parts of the index
during processing.
So this is highly unattractive.
It means it gets good theoretical bounds, we get good amatized bounds, but nevertheless
difficult to implement and also can have spiky,
expensive performance.
Because it could be that we have to rebuild something.
Therefore, this is also not so super attractive.
Therefore, I now show you the pragmatic solutions.
Now, if you talk to somebody
in more form a theoretical computer scientist,
a theoretical computer science,
of course, it will be unhappy because this,
strictly speaking, this is only heuristics,
not a conducting URT solution.
But the advantage is,
This is pretty easy to implement and gives you a 90% solution.
So most problems are fixed if you do this.
So basically what we do is, so the minimum what we have to do is to handle variable SAS
records as well is we modify the split logic.
So what we do is when a page overflows, so we look at all my values and of course a traditional
solution would say, this is all my values in sorted order.
traditional way solution would say you pick the median as separator.
Okay, median.
Now for fixed size records, that's fine.
If you have variable size records, then we don't do this.
Instead, we look at, for example, 20% around the median.
So we go to the left and the right.
And within this range, we pick the smallest in the sense of the shortest.
So not smallest in the short order, but the shortest value.
We pick the shortest value in this range and that we propagate as separator.
Now if you have ties, so if there are multiple values
that are as short, then of course we prefer the value
that is closest to the median.
Okay, so this is a pragmatic solution,
pretty easy to implement.
Now strictly speaking, it's not optimal.
You can construct inputs where this still behaves poorly,
but is unlikely that you encounter this.
Yeah, so the worst terrible things that can happen
can be taken with this.
And you can do something similar for bike loading.
So when you bike loading, you ought to look at, okay,
If I would take one value more, a few values more or less,
do I get better separators?
And if yes, you prefer the shortest separators you can get
while still keeping the fill degree of a page within a certain percentage.
And by doing this, you get much better separators than before.
Okay, now I see that if I check the clock, I'm running out of time now.
Yeah, so let's stop here and we look at last few more B3 tricks in the next lecture and
then we will look at other index structures too.
Okay, thank you.